now the latest on britain morning for
queen elizabeth thousands of people
stood in line all night waiting to view
the queen's coffin and many of them are
still
waiting this morning look at the line
roxanna siberia is outside westminster
hall keeping an eye out on the crowd of
mourners roxanna good morning to you the
line never stops and it keeps moving
it doesn't stop gayle these well-wishers
are now minutes from seeing the queen
lying in state looking at an online
tracker the line snakes back three miles
and it's moving pretty fast so the
hundreds of thousands expected here can
pass through by monday morning
queen elizabeth ii left her london home
for the last time saluted by cannons
and witnessed by tens of thousands most
in somber silence
[Applause]
others seeing her coffin broke out in
applause
performed with military precision the
procession journeyed at 75 drum beats
per minute
past london's storied landmarks king
charles iii and his three siblings
followed his sons william and harry
marched side by side despite the recent
rift
at the medieval westminster hall a
service honored britain's longest
reigning monarch and the royal family
quietly departed
delivering her to the nation
outside thousands formed the line
stretching for miles a few camped out
since monday she's always been around
for us you know others like abichima
waited for hours to say goodbye to their
queen why did you want to come here and
pay your respects
the queen's always been there since i
was alive and i've just she's a feminine
kind of icon for me i suppose so i just
wanted to say thank you for her service
i wanted to come to just pay my last
respects to the manager the queen who
did so much for britain and ultimately
led where we are today and sets the
example so high for you know the younger
generation coming up like me how old are
you
15. and she was 96. yeah but you could
still relate to her i can still relate
to her that's pretty amazing yeah
it's queen elizabeth the second for you
by evening they joined crowds filing
past the queen's coffin day and night
some bowing their heads or overcome with
emotion
what was it like seeing the queen's
coffin it was very moving very very
moving we spoke with chima again after
she left the hall this lady that i
thought was going to live forever is
finally gone and it just makes you look
at your
family your friends your immortality
and just make sure that you try to do
the right thing by everybody you know
from now on
the white house says president biden
talked to the new king yesterday and
spoke of the late queen's dignity and
constancy mr biden has said he'll attend
her funeral on monday along with around
500 heads of state and foreign
dignitaries gail
a perfect send-off for what appears many
people believe was a perfect queen
roxanna siberia we thank you i saw
interviews guys with people in line who
said you know you could be standing here
for over 25 hours and someone said she
served us for 70. years the least i
could do is stand here for her put it in
perspective i think so too i think so
too and i like the variety of people
that are waiting in line
and it's moving and it's moving